least the last three games what's
allowed you to be so comfortable so
early in your career
you know i think zach has done a great
job of
asking what
i'm comfortable with and calling those
plays
and he understands what i like in
certain situations we have a meeting the
night before every week that you know i
go through my top three calls in every
situation that we have and he calls them
one two three um so he's been doing a
great job of calling plays
and then you know we have great players
on the outside that
i know understand zone coverage
understand what we're trying to do with
every single play
bill was your first nfl win what was it
like in the uh the locker room
afterwards just celebrating with the
guys it was a lot of fun it was a lot of
fun um
but you know it's one it's one game
there's
12 more so
you know we're gonna enjoy this for
five hours and then come back to work
tomorrow correct the mistakes and move
on to baltimore you said after your
first touchdown pass you didn't really
care where the ball went i think you
said your mom might get it
um after your first win do you have a is
there any kind of special presentation
is the ball going somewhere is there
anything commemorative you might do it's
going back in the ball bag you only get
so many great good balls that you know
i'm very particular about the balls that
i throw um
so it's going right back in the game
ball bag we'll be using it again
[Music]
joe burrow gets his first nfl win
winning is fun
maybe he's got magic johnson doing his
tweets as well i think magic johnson
putting in work for a lot of people but
joe burrow is awesome he is great i
talked to him after that press
conference
and when he explained to me this whole
thing the ball's going back in the bag
because i'm thinking what are you talk
what do you mean it's going back in the
bag yeah i mean you're like saving
you're not you're not even gonna put it
on
the on the mantel like it's that sacred
he's like no i want to use it again it's
a good ball not they don't come around
very often where you get a good ball
like that i want to keep using that
football so i guess if they ever give
him a game ball that that isn't a good
ball that's the one that'll end up on uh
on the trophy case somewhere well yeah i
mean you just you don't mess with a
quarterback and a hot football i mean
that's just the way it is you do you
have a
as you know the nfl they used to be very
strict with the rules of footballs but
you you have a number of footballs you
play within a game now the nfl is much
more loose with
you know what football you do use to
where you can have as long as it's
inflated probably as long as it's
inflated properly right but as long as
you have like you you can go like oh i
have four or five favorite footballs and
this is what i want to play with and i
know people out there might go what the
hell a football is a football but it's
not they're not all constructed exactly
the same some of them the leather is
just a little bit different a little
more tacky better to grip so you like
that and some of the footballs just have
the right amount of like
protruding laces right to where it just
comes out the right distance to where it
feels really good when you wrap your
knuckle around that and you go man my
fingertips are on a sticky part of the
leather football
it's great laces and you know it's just
part of a quarterback in their
you know what neurotic uh brains and and
how they like things and help them be
successful
but there's nothing neurotic about it i
mean you think about the other sports
out there like baseballs or baseballs
basketballs for the most part for the
most part are basketballs except
remember when they tried to like change
the
like they came up with some
revolutionary ball that everybody in the
nba hated like 15 20 years ago hockey
pucks are hockey pucks like nobody's
nobody's judging the feel of a hockey
puck but even like when you're kids
yeah i remember in the 70s we gather in
this field in the neighborhood every day
and everybody brings a football and it
throws into a pile and they which one's
the best one which was the new which the
bag you you pick them up and you hold
them and you throw them you know which
one's the best exactly and it's the same
thing and that's there's a charm to that
right that never goes away but it's how
it feels when you throw it and when you
have one that works
even if it's been awarded to you as the
game ball for your first ever nfl win
back it goes into the bag and uh uh you
use it again because it may help you
again he doesn't give a damn about one
win he's not here to win once that's the
other thing too he just won 15 and
didn't lose any last year he's not
looking for any one game oh my gosh i
won a game in the nfl i bet he could
care less he expects to win again this
week
i asked him about the tie from last week
because i know how dismayed he was at
going 0-2 it's like did it feel better
at all that you didn't lose last week
and he said i didn't know how to feel i
was walking around the locker room
saying to guys how should i feel about
this i don't like it but should i feel
that way yeah like what is this really
now if you ask the eagles it's a good
thing it helped get them in first place
after what happened yesterday in the nfc
yeah and that that tie can come in handy
the tie is the ultimate we don't have to
screw around with eight levels of tie
breaker
because unless other teams have ties
we'll know where the bengals stand
without saying well who did they play
who did they beat because they're either
gonna be ahead by a half game or they're
gonna be behind by a half game and uh
yeah it would have been better to get
the win but it's better that a hell of a
lot better than losing it is to have
that
one two and one instead of one and three
for the bank mike mike that's what's
crazy about what doug peterson said last
week on monday i i don't know if you
remember but he came out and he goes i
wish i would have gone for it i wish i
would have just done that like they had
they're going to have like a fourth and
11 or fourth and 12.
and i just i was shocked by that i mean
i know he likes to be aggressive and and
kind of like push the envelope all the
time but damn that that tie like you
said it it's going to come in real handy
and especially in the nfl nfc leased
right now
i mean yeah
seven eight and one might give you the
tiebreaker over all the other seven and
nine teams this year in that division i
also asked joe burrow how he's feeling
through four games because he has been
rocked multiple times we saw it last
week malik jackson blew him up he got
hit hard yesterday he's not shying away
from contact he said after the game
against the browns week too it makes me
feel like a football player i said what
does mom think about all this he said
she's used to it she's been watching me
play since i was in the third grade she
knows i can take a few hits and as the
guys pointed out last night on football
night in america the ravens are up now
oh gosh so more for and they're 13 and a
half point favorites over the bengals
going into week five so uh you know
i i wanted to get him to talk a little
bit about the difference between the sec
and the nfl because everybody always
says the sec is the closest thing to the
nfl there's still a hell of a gap there
no and he didn't want to go down he
didn't want to go down that path because
i you know i he he understands it's
humbling when you think
that you are facing the ultimate
competition in football and mastering it
in the sec and you realize the golf the
chasm yes between the best college
football players in any given year and
the best of the best who have burst
through their own personal ceilings
reached an even higher level of
achievement at the nfl and they're all
from 10 15 20 years or more depending
upon whether you're facing tom brady or
not yeah they're all in the same blender
of 32 teams it's a lot harder than
anything you ever see in college yeah a
lot harder yes the talent the sec talent
level is special we know that it's the
best in college football but it's yes
it's not the nfl you're not having a
sixty a fifth year veteran who's not
only as physically gifted as that junior
in college but he's stronger knows more
techniques knows more nuance of the game
there's none of that let alone the
coaching there's no 20-hour rule in the
nfl the game plans are so much more
nuanced creative and you're dealing with
just guys who are you know again
a lot of the guys in the nfl were the
joe burrows of their college football
team hey i'm the best player on the team
i'm the one who loves football i'm the
one that's going to lead us out of the
tunnel and now they're a corner or
safety or a linebacker but that kind of
guy who loves the game and takes pride
in it uh you see that more than that and
and yeah there's no comparison there
there's no doubt
alvin kamara the saints running back who
had a good game the saints got their 35
points
even though they gave up 14 on the front
end and 15 on the back and it was enough
to win
they had an incident that popped up late
saturday night
when they got to detroit 10 40 p.m
eastern they found out that michael
burton the team's only fullback had
tested positive
so
time to figure out who he's been in
contact with the contact tracers flagged
three people but there were four other
people he was sitting close to on the
plane so there were seven guys who had
to stay up until after one o'clock to
wait to have their noses swabbed so they
could be tested to see if they too were
positive and camaro was one of them
and he told me i really didn't sleep 1
15 i went to bed i kept waking up
checking my phone to see if there was
any news eventually
burton's positive turned out to be false
so everyone was in the clear but that
doesn't take away the disruption no
that's tough mayor's very pragmatic
about it he's like look is what it is
nobody cares they're not going to delay
the game for us they're not going to
feel bad for us we're not going to get
any extra points right we got to go play
right and they went and they played and
to their credit and he said the 14 to
nothing deficit had nothing to do with
it it didn't take them a while to get
started or anything it just happened
they were ready to play they were fine
and this is one of the inconveniences we
have to accept i mean again i go back to
when roger goodell refused to
acknowledge there's a competitive
advantage when teams have fans versus
when they don't have fans and what he
should have said was you ain't seen
nothing yet because there's going to be
an entire
gamut an entire array a universe of
inequities that happened this year to
try to hold 256 games together assuming
they even can't chris yeah that's right
i mean hey we're going to see that
tonight we got a guy that's not playing
and he's nickname is superman and he's
not when it comes to covet 19 it can
even get to it can even get to superman
but uh it just speaks you know to camara
the saints especially sean payton i mean
sean payton is just
you know he gets credit for being the
offensive genius that he is but the
other thing i think i love about sean
payton is just
his no nonsense no bs
you know attitude he brings to a team
there's never an excuse
and i just like that about him and it
rubs off and you see it in these type of
situations yeah they don't care they
don't blink at eye oh yep we're down 14
nothing so what we've been here before
we'll just keep doing what we do you
know we believe we're the better team
and the longer we play this game the
better team will prevail and that that's
exactly what they did and uh camara as
you mentioned in the last statement i
feel like ever since he got paid it's
just like
screw it pedal to the metal i'm gonna
take over every time i touch the ball
and uh he's been amazing
a dynamic that i alluded to earlier
about kevin stefanski and the browns
beyond stefanski acknowledging that he's
got to do a better job of getting the
ball in odell beckham jr's hands
playing at a t stadium
in dallas or arlington or wherever it is
dallas they're the dallas cowboys
they're in freaking dallas okay i know
i'm so sick of that crap i know but we
don't go over the giants
we're playing jerseys
is this an early is this an early
grievance that teams should be required
to either play in the city they're named
for or be named for the city and exactly
i don't have time to be sitting on tv
being like oh there's adele's or like no
you're the freaking dallas cowboys oh
sorry you built your stadium somewhere
else you're still the dallas cowboys i
don't care
anyway it's a 100 000 seat stadium and
they had 20 to 25 000 people there was
the first time the browns had been in
front of a crowd like that all year they
fed off of that they recognized that
it's special see cowboys players may
take it for granted because they're
there eight times a year the browns are
there once every eight years and between
miles garrett who grew up near that
stadium
baker mayfield who's got strong ties to
texas yeah odell beckham jr who knows a
thing or two about playing in that
stadium and playing against the cowboys
that that
caused the team
to want to show up and have a big
performance and i wish i had ridden that
feeling last week right ricocheted
around my torso and disappeared and i'm
not saying hey i i knew this was coming
no i dismissed it i had the thought and
i dismissed it and i wish i hadn't i
wish i would have i wish i would have at
least grabbed it and thought about it
and worked it through some because there
was something there and let me tell you
when it was 41 to 14.
i was thinking
bears cowboys 1985
when now look the 85 bears were a
special team but that's when we first
noticed
the 85 bears right when they went to
dallas and curb stopped the cowboys 44
nothing that's what it made me think of
this is a statement game and it changed
it wasn't a statement game 4938 isn't a
statement 4114 is 4938 is hey that's a
shootout and as it turns out the browns
had to hold on for their dear life
because the cowboys made it very
interesting late as they tend to do
but bottom line the browns this is not
the browns team that we're used to this
is the this is a franchise that won four
games in three seasons they've won three
games
in three weeks
and they rose to the occasion when's the
last time a brown's team rose to the
occasion
i can't remember it no can you chris no
i don't think i can either you were
saying and i was sitting there going i
don't know when when is that last time
i'm not even sure
you're you're exactly right about that
but you know they're showing some
toughness as a football team i think
that's that's what you're speaking of
they got a little bit of a you know a
vibe that way to where it's kind of like
okay yeah whatever but we're gonna get
it done and win the game i don't know
how it's gonna happen if it's gonna be
nick chubb or reverses or a baker
mayfield big pass but they seem like
they are building that confidence that
way and that's you know stefanski all
the way definitely i mean just what he's
done he's he's the one that's added that
toughness to their football team and
kind of their we know what they are they
have an identity you know we talk about
that all the time yeah their defense is
still a work in progress but offensively
they they have something to build on
there and they have something that we
talk about a lot where now you're really
good at one thing and it's gonna force
the defense's hand and hopefully
stefanski continue to push himself to
where he can be a step ahead all right i
got good at this they're going to start
doing this now what's you're going to be
your move off of it what is going to be
that next move and right now he seems to
be ahead of the curve there at least the
last few weeks
toughness the operative word the next
two games colts whoa we'll find out a
lot maybe the two best defenses
in the course of the next two weeks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports